hello and welcome to this video war
playing hornish ducks again and how is
seems to be in this pool the whole time
okay I'm he's a good player so let's see
what he can do here with the white
pieces in my petrov yeah whitey has a
wide choice on move ten I think the most
testing most testing is probably a three
on move ten but difficult to say really
there's so many options that are quite
transpositional yeah yeah a six is good
or Ruchi aid this is also not that's not
very critical then move order them
in these positions wide always has a
very slight pool it is not it's not much
but it is somehow there yeah why it has
a bit more space and somewhat easier
play normal would be c4 in this position
doesn't do it mm-hmm and this I don't
think it's very dangerous
what the heck should always hate that
and I don't think I've ever not lost a
game where the phone is ringing usually
I have the sound off I'm not sure why it
is on now stop it I'm not here yeah I
wonder if I wondered if Queen age 7 was
a move I don't think it was but okay hmm
what is he doing there okay I probably
want to stop F form
and see if I can maybe what is that
okay I'm taking him I have prevented F
form
okay so now is Sam this is a thing
interesting looking at c4 and having a
look f3 in mind
he has rook f1 dome that was that was a
bit of a hmm okay look f3 in this
position he has what exactly had an own
queen h7 I can take on c4 oh okay
now hmm not sure him I mean this is
definitely okay but I don't know if it
is best
if it takes pawn takes him and I'm
trying to play against the Jeep on
should still be equal
yeah got f5 yeah again it's probably
still equal let's do it though I don't
think I get anything better here so rook
h3 will win the H pawn I wonder if I
should call a five in this position will
be success stop the pawns okay now if I
take on g4 a couple of times and then
rook h3 I win the pawn or rook F five it
makes no big difference maybe it's okay
the new cage form okay it makes a
difference
okay let's go here so that I can cover
from the side there is very little
chance if I'm in front of the pawn there
are very little chances was probably
better English okay so now this one and
then I'm going to g8 he's got before but
that definitely weakens white structure
as well now I have some ideas to check
on the third and then go back go back I
mean going behind the pawns that's what
I'm trying to say let's see how to do
that I can go to to c6 first
now if I check him check again
I still don't win win anything down
yeah I don't win anything there so the
king the King March didn't help any
other way forward let me check no so I
still have to do it with this King it's
that's the beauty of being able to try
around a little bit so I probably have
to do this at some point maybe going
back is an option okay now I can go rook
h3 if I want and return to this idea I'm
not sure about it originally I wanted to
take before and play would be three
maybe that was better
yeah there is a drawer I guess the
anyway for me forward I can run to the C
pawn I don't need to make a decision now
you know I can still try around a little
bit
okay now it's rook t1 know what doesn't
work the idea to win would be a check
with the rook on the second ring I'm not
getting them I'm not getting them yeah
it was a draw anyway any idea like any
idea not not not that I see can walk all
the way back but what does it do okay is
there something I can do here
I mean I can theoretically this way I
can do Peru create rook e8 don't do it
don't do it that's the only way to lose
wow that was close I will create that
was very lucky okay so that rook T for
this work again
yeah I could have won the rook I should
have just made a drawer there of course
and the joy definitely was
I know I'm two points down and I was
extremely silly you should just make the
draw down and be okay with it
okay now you ask me how is that a draw F
and H pawn
hm I don't know I don't know I've never
looked at this in any in any sort of
detail
and it's not that I can analyze it now I
was an extremely silly in a silly way to
try to lose the game
okay let's see it set a draw now ob6 how
does he make any headway I don't know oh
I completely overlooked this move
whatever therefore they observed it it
was one of the most stupid games I can
remember and it's unfortunately a draw
if I take I mean
now come on that must be a drawing here
right can just stay here it's 130 moves
what a game
Jesus you got everything I mean I got a
full car yeah I'm playing very stupidly
for for wind and London to a loss of
London look that he didn't take Jesus no
wonder it's got everything in there yeah
Wow and it's a very long game yeah I
think if we how do we start there I
think we had a somewhat equal ish
position yeah I think that's roughly
equal now the computer is actually
liking white quite a bit down now it
goes a bit down with 0.4 it's more than
I thought it was yeah yeah it was quite
happy no can the engine says it's equal
maybe I had some semi some opportunity
that I didn't take I mean here this is
kind of clear that I should be a little
bit better I am see if c-5m it's a good
idea by the engine trade more f5 and I
have looked h3 that actually threatens
rook takes h5 I did not spot that hi
it's nice and that also threatens this
move
camelids but that's better than my
movement quite clearly
so yeah and taking these endings are
usually just to draw I'm a bit surprised
that the engine gives me zero point
seven that sets a 1.7 that is a lot so I
was okay with covering it from the side
but you don't get get anywhere really I
mean maybe my original intention was
okay I had this little back and forth
you have some time there now I went to
page three my original intention was to
take and put this here and trying to do
something in this position but okay it's
probably it's just a draw as well I am
okay yeah so I don't think I have a
serious winning opportunity here aibee
aibee I can take before first take tank
I'm still quite amazed that the engine
gives me such a huge advantage it could
be when that could be ruined
yeah it's tough to analyze in this
context so we need much more time to
figure that out and here we are this is
a drawing I mean I tried something that
was like extremely silly in the first
place okay here I had something yeah so
this was a moment where yeah where maybe
that was a possible idea that's the only
idea that you have that you can do
something like this and this could be a
win and it did is a when yeah so they
cannot take the pawn which means he has
to do this this this and then I get here
okay that that looks very critical so
that was the that idea so I had this
opportunity but I wanted to improve this
somehow with c4 and then I didn't get it
anymore this opportunity so I could
actually do it him yeah so that might
win then yeah and after c4 it's a draw
until i blundered my rupee and that was
that was the silliest move ever yeah the
debt just that is just too crazy no but
I would have shortened the whole thing
quite a bit and then okay I was really
not what did I do that I can still go
back there and just easily draw where
there was completely silly you know
Andrew H 1 Forster but I went here I'm
probably basically lost
we wrote that he is on mobile okay yeah
and here I said a table base position
yeah okay
table but it's a table base draw and
it's it's I'm not sure I'm going to just
click ahead a little bit and you see a
we are we are still on a draw if I'm
defending this somehow perfectly it
would be just a complete coincidence so
here look age five is it wrong yeah it
makes kind of sense but okay you have to
play and now it's lost
there was a drawdown no now it's maybe
strong not still at all Organa drawn and
so we we didn't play it like Complete
Idiot's I think with it's just seconds
on the clock it's it's it clear that you
cannot play perfectly there okay and
that game it kind of everything in lots
of very strange decisions of course I
hope you still enjoyed it yeah thanks
for watching